shouts all the married [ __ ] I'm one I
mean I'm a married Caucasian I'm married
- are you the game oh I see what you did
there
I'm a polygamist you know that hey shots
of the Mormons shout-out to Janelle -
God the Jimmer Fredette you know I went
to save his day right look the [ __ ]
Farrakhan got up - he was like yeah man
all my wives in the house I was like I
want to live like Farrakhan how many
wife is very I don't know who knows what
he's the man yeah I I'm a polygamous
that's all you need to know and you're
also a Muslim yes sir but I just had
some 40 - so let me ask you this how
long have you been a practice a
practicing Muslim I mean you know
everybody practice you gotta practice to
get better hang on Sam but there's been
a faith that you followed I'm a vice
Lord shoutout to the Vice little shots
of Chicago I'm vice Lord before I'm a
man and in a vice Lord and everything
else after that although I'm a man
father and then Vice Lords and
everything else that so but like cuz I'm
an atheist so I'm not somebody who's
religious in any capacity I feel you
what I rock would rock reviews I love
everybody's views represent what at what
point in time did you because I've seen
you poach your praying rug but you know
and talk about praying and all that like
what point in time did you commit to
that faith Oh like it wasn't always the
case when my grandfather died in like
2001 mm-hmm and like we was going to
like um Baptist Church our whole life
not like one of the reverends there I'm
gonna say - [ __ ] named [ __ ] that [ __ ]
his name was pastor Davis you know I'm
saying this is my forget it Gary any
areas that a whole church called New
Hope he was using my [ __ ] past at New
Hope the [ __ ] was at my
granddaddy funeral like flirting with my
mom doing all kind of [ __ ] and like
[ __ ] came out about the [ __ ] afterwards
you know why I'm an atheist to continue
bitch-ass [ __ ] exactly I feel you on
that so that you know I mean in there
like after that man you know when I
start hanging around a lot of like the
older like Lords like no love shopping
no love
a lot of people don't know no but he
like you know vice Lord is in Chicago
area missing Gary being home another
shot another but like guys like that
like showed me the Islamic doctrine with
in life you know I mean so I seen that
in and I was like you know the no pork
you know I mean in in like my [ __ ] you
know I got gun charters in you know when
you go to the county you gonna dick with
other lords and stuff like that
specially like look at you you [ __ ] up
older older guys and stuff like that you
know they teach you things you know I
mean so I just you know kept you know
kind of you know following that and
living better as I sit and drink 1942 I
think a lot of people that are watching
the interview get a lot of people
watching they never you don't know what
the Vice Lords are cuz they're not from
the Midwest they don't need to know what
we are we're silent so your secret weed
nothing you know what is the most vice
Lord I don't know where that is